nous sommes nous sommes en pleine
semaine de l'industrie nous en avons
parlé ce soir on va s'intéresser un
autre sujet toujours autour de
l'entreprise mais de la création
d'entreprise cette fois-ci exactement
michel et là vous êtes directeur de la
bg oki un réseau d'information et de
conseil pour la création d'entreprises
alors bg e pour bureaux de boutiques de
gestion des
outils de gestion pour entreprendre pour
entreprendre alors donc vous aussi vous
avez créé une semaine nationale la
semaine créer son entreprise évidemment
donc l'antenne des yvelines a suivi
c'est la troisième édition alors que
va-t-il se passer en particulier cette
semaine alors donc en effet on est dans
le cadre d'une semaine nationale
le réseau des bg organise sa sur tout le
territoire puisque c'est le premier
réseau national de soutien à la création
d'entreprises en france
donc nous on relaie cet événement sur le
département des yvelines
est donc l'objet de cette manifestation
c'est à la fois d'encourager la création
d'entreprises est également de
sensibiliser les porteurs de projets à
l'importance de se faire accompagner de
se former de se renseigner
lorsqu'on envisage de créer sa propre
entreprise
est ce que vous disiez c'est vrai
beaucoup plus de chances de réussir et
de pérenniser sa société quand on a
accompagné que quand on ne l'est pas
vous aviez quelques données oui oui
voilà les statistiques sont assez nette
à ce sujet
au niveau
national global on a un taux de
pérennité des entreprises de 66% sert
qu'une entreprise qui se créent ou trois
ans
à 66 % le lait les entreprises sont
encore en vie quand elles sont
accompagnées alors nous on a encore
validé cette statistique par un sondage
très précis il ya 82 % des entreprises
qu'on accompagne il y a trois ans qui
sont encore en vie donc si avec un
chiffre à retenir ce serait celui-ci
d'autant qu'il a été
soulignée dans le rapport du 14 février
de la cour des comptes sur l'évaluation
des politiques publiques et il a été
souligné
l'importance justement de
l'accompagnement dans le cas de
l'appareil pérennité des créations
d'entreprises en france alors concernant
l'activité emmené m en elle-même il ya
notamment un événement majeur samedi oui
alors en fait nous on décline localement
cet événement en deux manifestations
demain vendredi et après demain samedi
alors demain c'est
une
une réunion d'information collective
voilà eric et grands tous les quinze
jours donc où on accueille tout public
notamment des demandeurs d'emploi et on
organise samedi un événement
supplémentaire cette fois ci plus
orienté vers un public salariés d'où le
l'organisation sur un samedi et on
propose deux ateliers 1 à 10 heures et
un à 11h30 et dans toutes ses
manifestations à un conseiller
professionnel anime ces ateliers
est donc propose de l'information
qualifiée sur la création d'entreprise
il aborde des aspects juridiques il
aborde des questions relatives aux aides
qu'elles soient de formation qu'elles
soient financières et notamment les
aides spécifiques au département des
yvelines car on travaille sur l'ensemble
du département et en fonction des lieux
d'implantation il ya différents
dispositifs et toute autre question
sur la formalisation du projet au
travers d'un business plan et et tout le
travail sur les aspects financiers
prévisionnels étude de marché c est au
final mal et malgré la morosité ça ne
m'empêche pas finalement du monde de
venir vous voir maintenant et nous
renier ces manifestations un succès
certain tous les quinze jours on a de
plus en plus de monde qui vient de voir
c'est vrai que c'est un petit peu un la
création entreprises d'un secteur qui
lorsqu'il ya croissance économique ça
crée des opportunités et lorsqu'on est
dans une situation un petit peu
difficile des personnes sans emploi
cherche à se réinsérer
professionnellement en créant leur
entreprise
dans tous les cas c'est un projet
étudiée très sérieusement et si vous
souhaitez justement franchir le pas vous
lancer créer votre entreprise on vous
renvoie vers la baie jeu pour beaucoup
plus d'information merci à michel et la
merci aussi à magali la faune vous êtes
donc un chef de projet à renault et nous
parlions avec vous tout à l'heure de la
semaine de l'industrie la chronique de
l'écho qui se poursuit à présent avec
les infos en plus et wii première fois
en plus c'est la possibilité de payer
son stationnement par téléphone portable
à rambouillet depuis la semaine dernière
la ville propose auto aux automobilistes
de payer via leur smartphone grâce au
service paybyphone en donnant en fait le
numéro de carte bancaire et le numéro
d'immatriculation de son véhicule donc
eu besoin finalement de passer par le
parc m la première première ville pardon
du département le faire table qui est
dorénavant indispensable voilà voilà
plus qu'un simple accessoire d'avoir son
smartphone oui non compliqué voilà une
autre information en plus ce soir oui
c'est auchan vélizy qui est le premier
hypermarché de france en termes de
chiffre d'affaires c'est un classement
qui a été réalisé par magazine linéaires
qui l'a réalisé 280 12,2 millions
d'euros en 2012 et également le
carrefour saint quentin en yvelines qui
est 96ème donc surtout de la france avec
126,5 millions d'euros de chiffre voilà
pour cette information concernant
carrefour une autre information
également concernant un centre
commercial une boutique c'est officiel
depuis la fin de l'après-midi l'enseigne
ikea aura droit à son extension sur le
site de plaisir de 14000 à 24 mille
mètres carrés est la commission et
départementale a donné son feu vert nous
y reviendrons au cours de nos prochaines
éditions on termine la chronique de
l'écho avec l'agenda traditionnellement
mis aux premières dates à retenir on va
rappeler les portes ouvertes de la baie
jeu samedi matin des conseillers donc
vous attendre pour deux ateliers
gratuits à 10h et 11h30 et les
informeront donc ceux qui souhaitent
créer leur entreprise aide financière
conseils pour construire son projet
formation possible en rendez vous donc à
l'abbé gea est bonne et puis deuxième
date ce sont les portes ouvertes au cfa
cette fois samedi de 9 heures à 17
heures et dimanche de 9h à 13h au
programme visible des locaux et
information sur les formations trop
esthétique boulangerie coiffure ou
encore prothèse dentaire merci clair
pour ce point complet sur l'économie
comme chaque jeudi on retrouve donc la
semaine prochaine